we're putting out real fire and a lot of
volume [ __ ] look
follow you of content she does intense
Yakut [ __ ]
oh I seriously I don't really if I'm
really pissed off
well if I would leave Islam I'd rather
die than I would die no let's do this
once right
okay you did have a fight right oh dear
oh can you not record them none of this
is gonna be on the show
um I think you and I should get into a
fight and be in the same team soon
because we love each other we don't to
find each other let's go fight other
people and then assess each other in
over my face on what we did it's up
there that's a good idea right I think
you guys should go jump somebody for the
Powerball hey let's go let's go what two
buildings over and do like DMX like just
a mere letter yo who wants it okay
he's a gentle giant that one go get him
really mad though yeah is really just
awful just like me you're naked you guys
stop talking about it it's so cool it's
crazy
pretty excited I'm excited I'm like how
nervous have excited I think you do
really good job awesome like I'm really
thankful you're here I could do to bring
a lot about you and and I'd love to hear
how it's going for you so far
yeah it's just it's a pleasure having
people that care about what you do and
responsibilities and if you like what
you're doing is notice and actually
matter so that's kind of your product
out here at boot in spades
I mean I could see brother Skeeter glad
we finally do this yeah what can i
interview up anything
um I super be like I think right now my
entire thing is learn as much as I can
and that's what I want to do so in terms
of like as someone that's just young
what six months out of university yes
working is really interesting what do
you think I could be doing other than
juice it up like trying to imitate or
just like picking up a good thing I
think the number one thing I would do if
I were you
knowing what I know is becoming a
practitioner you don't to be a personal
brand like me creating something around
an interest like music head McGee or
whatever you know either real to you or
a thing photography boy forty four like
I don't care what it is right but
becoming really great at snapchat
musically you know dubsmash like all
these things that are emerging new
because they'll give you a cadence and a
skillset it's a preview being good at
Socialcam helping me with mine helped me
with you know Instagram video helped me
with snapchat it's an evolution I always
believe in creating you're a competitive
advantage for yourself that experience
doesn't allow so there's people here
that work 7 10 15 years they have that
advantage right what you could have the
advantage is capturing a voice that
doesn't exist yet right yeah that makes
okay oh that's the tangible
black-and-white advice cool cool
sweet I'll say thank you see ya hips see
again talk to you soon yep I have to get
every time so today would be nice and is
hacking daily visions if you got put my
hand on it next time Dan Grossman
although I think yeah your father's
anyway I should have a some records
pretty cool my father's are amazing this
is entrepreneurship fake the musician
you can fake those in entrepreneurship
everybody in America everybody watching
this right now
it needs the American thing to believe
people don't think of entrepreneurship
as a skill right they don't think they
can be LeBron or be you know Nine Inch
Nails or be 50 or cent but everybody
looks at me and says I can do that yeah
they don't understand that it's a talent
by the way the other thing that's it's
more practical to actually recognize I'm
a talent and let's say they think of a
Haunter I'm the best yeah then being a
68 is actually quite financially and
Happiness worthy whereas if you look at
the Brawn and he's a hundred being a 68
means that like you'll spend a lot of
time in rectly exactly like like it's
there's a different right it costs you
money to try to be a 68 musician you
paid 15,000 demo you have an overhead
like you can't pay rent this thing being
a 60 even for the people that are
clearly understanding that they're not
me talent wise yeah it's actually quite
practical to be a 68 yeah and that's
where it's into right right yeah cuz you
can start surprised with your back in
your office winner okay sorry I gotta go
okay
and II pull up the secret ship a lot of
you don't know about this yet never
really promoted entrepreneur answered on
YouTube what's the unique URL
entrepreneurship answer yup
so each of you tube same as we're always
doing I have it broken out we're gonna
see how it performs so retargeting so
these people have watched your videos
people in years I'm mister this is my
multi kill what do you think maybe
that's an over allocation to that um I
believe is just for the cops mhm gut
tell you on that it's not the podcast it
because its energy secretary you can
never really win cuz it's not it's a
podcast that's the auto of a video of
course like we were if I made a podcast
if I actually did about us we'd wait you
know what we need to talk about the you
know what's the fun real quick help
think about this I have a very
interesting thing that I've never talked
about but I've posted the Instagram
photo and it always [ __ ] of everybody
which is basically my core college
friends were black kids which I and it's
and it's very interesting because I
didn't go into like hip-hop music like I
don't play in an african-american
minority world in my career as a matter
of fact if anything tech investing
forced me deeper into old white dude
that I've ever been right because at
least liquor business had some um I need
to find you know I do not like I even
though I like the furthest I go into
like sexism and things of that nature is
like I'm girly I'm apathetic like you
know like which is true and it's why I
think I'm good by the way that's why I
think I'm good at that like I actually
just think I'm a girl I know it's weird
but you know like I feel um I'm just is
it not no great see exactly so like I
don't know here's what I know I know
that I'm motherly I know that I like
having this because I'm like I'm gonna
take care of you guys like I know that I
know the reason I get mad at everybody
is they don't realize my 5149 probably
has a lot more to do with my own ego
slash motherly thing it's not even ego
like I sang that as a hedge it's because
I like it
I genuinely believe that I can do that
like that's right
Sego like I genuinely believe under my
watch you can win more right and then
what I may want to do for askgaryvee and
I'm not kidding let's see how fast I can
do this we may answer one question one
and then I want you to run all the
b-roll and everything you just have that
happen play music over it be like this
is why there wasn't a gary vee
askgaryvee today this is what happened
during that time slot could be kind of
cool just see what everybody does yeah
it could be kind of just let's just be
mixing it up a little all right let's do
the a barter videos what are they the
thing that I think will stun you or make
you triple reaffirmed how good this
place is is the intent is always right
you could you could be upset because you
think I'm stupid and I'm wrong but
that's a very different thing than the
intent and I think if I can drill that
home we can build something very special
so that's my ambition and I really
really have no idea if I can pull it off
eight years ago when you read a yelp
review you're gonna hear that all you're
gonna call it Tony sorry can you just um
by be 5 minutes somehow some way so next
time this is on the calendar come with
your best questions right there guys
thank you Tony its Gary Vaynerchuk how
are you so obviously you know you and I
have these great feelings towards each
other but you know I'm see when I'm
talking every day but I think you're
gonna be affected by what I have a say
which is I believe that snapchat is
going through a very similar Twitter
2007 YouTube 2006 kind of moment and I
personally believe that you could be
very dominant on the platform and it
could be a benefit for you and the
things that you want to communicate to
the world whereas both you and I have
very large followings on Twitter
and other platforms it doesn't matter
how many people you can potentially
reach it matters how many people you
actually reach right when I think about
your world Jesus now I see a world where
you're about to board a plane or you're
going to the bathroom or they're like in
between meetings you take out your phone
you say guys this is what you need to be
thinking about you make two or three
ten-second videos it's a 30-second ramp
and millions of people consume it not a
man take care bye before are better off
our ally to schedule at one minute
meeting and then take the two minutes to
write that email because it's 94.7%
chance that I'm going to look at it be
like oh there's a lot there I'd rather
talk to him just that's it so that's why
I have enough to work how do you hit
anything over like 10 ready cents
anything that is in the body of the
email got rise a problem to put
everything my god this is how great is
it yeah the title games the game ah
sending emails fully in the title it
works
it's respecting the other person's time
um alright so basically about that do
you rock you think I should do more of
like the kind of like those TV shows
that look like I gave your boners I
start doing that break third wall yeah
the third wall attacks very uh animation
attitude a much better job did you see
what you said I was pretty oh you called
an inversion which wasn't he called
bringing the third parole wall which is
exactly one of them looks just like you
know you're right you do the first edit
of daily people talk about can you give
a 1/2 dagger to 0 cos I'm a losing
shaman negative 2 right that loss loss
that Celtics game last night
brutal alright so what do we got yeah
I'm ok with that
yeah I'm good perfect tremendous
get Minnie get utena Matta feeling jets
gonna be the best stories yes so um that
uh this is now on KP you can see you say
no no like that feels like a split
second but you can somebody stands up at
a black sweaters like you guys I was a
long lovely
it's crazy the stuff it's the craziest
there's nothing like that in sports
portside I'm as close to you right now
as I am collect lighters yeah that's
about was in your left
oh yeah like fudge what I know is you in
junior together yelling at the rap it's
so bonkers or so good they're so big
Orion
yeah I think about a bad guy rapido
I invested in medium and producthunt and
Lux valet and a lot of good bets that
need time to play out that's how we got
here
very cool
Terry hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk um just
trying to get a hold of you I'm in tight
meetings here but I'd love to help out
if I can I'm gonna try one more number
if I can't make that but I'm gonna have
to go to this other meeting and then
we'll try later if that's still works
for your deadline but I've empathy that
I may not have played I let's get up the
reschedule or not happen that's okay it
happens good good effort no yeah right
here right here you need you to beat you
man honor it dance me I'm sorry I'm
Tyler so brother it's a big dog can see
you can see - Manny Guerin bond well
such a pleasure
Alton Wisconsin some Jersey I love it
man I don't have it I love it thank you
I figure you have I love it I love
altoon this is great the mail
we need to frame this one we need the
frame can you uh put it and put it put a
note form bank socks cool thank you so
much it's really nice trying to know sir
you're in the emotional center yeah Oh
Oh what is going on here you're about to
find out there's a lot going on here
yeah there's a lot going on here
so this is like this whole game like
this whole everything the reason I think
I invented as a young kid I want to buy
the New York Jets
it was it seemed like a big enough goal
that would take me a long enough time to
make what I really love about
entrepreneurship which is I love the
process under you because I love the
game
you know the athletes that retire is a
37 they've been washed up for four years
but just know that the last time they
take a snap that's it do thankful I am
that I'm an entrepreneur and businessman
that our game lasts forever until I take
my last breath I love the process as a
matter of fact if you want to get really
deep and weird if I want people to
understand that at its purest form
intent is the only thing that matters
the reason I'm not scared of anything is
I know where my intent is I mean that I
wrote crush it I knew that an
unbelievable amount of people we're
gonna make millions of dollars if they
read it I'm gonna basically predicted
everything that happened seven years ago
yeah right and I knew that it cost $13 I
wasn't selling some being my mastermind
or for 50,000 a month and I'm gonna just
tell you enough that you never can be
sick I literally obsessed with putting
myself out of business
yeah I want to give people the tools I
have no interest in I make a book every
two years before I booked a scaredy's
coming it's I don't know 12 19 not 17
dollars i put on [ __ ] askgaryvee show
every [ __ ] minute like this all comes
out of me get in mine yeah and and and
so what I'm excited about is I think I'm
playing it so differently than everybody
else that looks like me there's a big
difference between becoming rich and
becoming wealthy and it's predicated on
talent but another weird little thing
it's called [ __ ] patience the other
thing I'm sure you get a lot of and I'm
getting bombarded on snapchat
every goddamn snapchat thing now is like
Gary how do I immediately get ex here
it's the number one thing how do i how
do I become the winner this year right
you know as I'm like I'm always like
would you rather become a millionaire
period or not at all intent is not being
talked about enough
listen actions are greater than words
but before you get into actions they
oftentimes not always are mapping to
your intent and I just think it's
people's North Star it's their religion
it's their thing I'm always comfortable
my skin because I know what my intent is
and if I mess up then I'll say I'm sorry
but it's really exciting to know that it
didn't start or come from a bad place
makes me it puts me at peace and it puts
me at peace as a professional it puts me
at peace as a human being
let's and I think the world needs more
people another way everybody doesn't
different everybody's got different
doors and the truth is I'm worried about
sometimes I did something and then you
start digging and realize didn't do it
the right way the right so that's not
interesting right
but I felt through our call we were back
well I mean look the interest in the
cities in your good sales by the enemy
who sit here and smile and all that good
energy
yeah you're going to win because all day
yeah all day when you grow up a huge
sports can the thought of like like even
though I dream to own the Jets
I clean this big ambition but I didn't
realize how wealthy that have to be
along the way to actually pull it off
so some weird I thought it was more real
that I would buy the Jets but have mixed
courtside seats because I was so I only
think about that I didn't care about all
the other stuff so in a weird way I'm
like
in a weird way that's incredible for me
like those I think are the biggest
tickets in sports
nothing like it and then they're all
things I didn't think about which is
like ice cubes sitting two seats from
you you know like at the wharf or you
know the way my career's played out like
I'm friendly with Carmelo so him coming
over and giving me gas
like yesterday there was a vowel right
behind me and it's me and porzingis I'm
he be yelling at the rock like like and
all my friends text me mainly power
rocks yeah
I'm like industry began the low five is
here I just put up on Instagram
check it Gary beaten
really good day today
it's some stuff happening yeah great day
and so just wishing you all a great
night and or actually probably great day
Oh